tim martin the chair of the jd
weatherspoon says that pubs
should reopen at the same time as
non-essential retail
stores because the industry is on its
knees and
must restart soon to save jobs and he
joins me now good to see you this
morning tim
a pretty impassioned plea from you uh
to the government you won't be the only
sector
uh making making your case on what basis
do you argue yours
well really on the fact that if you take
our pub company for example we have
50 we've had 50 million visits
customer visits since the 4th of july
last year
and we've had no outbreak among
customers
it's counter-intuitive but if you
operate
social distancing policies which have
been agreed with the health authorities
before last summer and you have the
proper hygiene
regulations in place then uh
you avoid uh uh transfer of the virus in
pubs a lot of people don't believe that
but i think all
stats show that it's private houses
care homes factories and so on have a
much
worse experience than pubs so
so we think we can make them covered
secure
tim you're saying most people don't
believe that but crucially
the people who do believe it is the
government and its scientific advisors
and well the the government has shut
pubs three times completely
and instigated a raft of of uh
unscientific measures like curfews and
you can only have a pint with a
substantial meal
so we're worried that it's going from
pillar to post
and they've said for example that
or it's been indicated that you can open
up
within gardens in in april but that'll
make the whole industry
unprofitable it might be the old pub
that makes buck so we're worried about
the finances
the million or so jobs that have been
lost in pubs and similar types of
businesses
and the amount of money we contribute to
the economy it all has to be
taken into the into the mix
when you were raising funds recently
from shareholders you talked about a
best-case scenario
of reopening at the end of march and
with sales at 50
of normal level is is that still your
hope
yes the end of march would be the same
as the first lockdown which was about
three months and the difference this
time
is that vast swathes of the country
including myself by this afternoon will
have been vaccinated so this time you've
got vaccination as well
so we don't think the lock down should
be longer and there was no rise in
cases once pubs reopened last summer
that happened quite a bit later you talk
about vaccinations there will you insist
on staff or indeed customers having been
vaccinated before they can come in
well we actually haven't crossed that
bridge i think it would be an
unusual situation been trading for over
40 years and i know some people have
been training for longer and we haven't
had a sort of passport control
at the door of the pub saying
that people have to have a vaccination
so i'm
suspicious about that idea myself but
we'll just have to see how things pan
out in the country it partly depends on
what the virus itself does of course
talking about things that you've uh that
you may post in your pub you courted
criticism
recently by having anti-lockdown posters
displayed in in some of your pubs they
have now been removed and but i'm just
wondering if you regret that
um no i think there's a strong case
which has been made by
many many people that the type of hard
lockdown that you've had in the uk
doesn't work you've got to remember
we've had three lockdowns
and we've got the highest fatality rate
per million people in the entire world
sweden i just updated the numbers this
morning has got
half the fatalities per million people
of the uk
and it hasn't had a hard lockdown but i
think people get lost
and can we come here for a moment please
because the swedish fatality rate
as is well known does far eclipse it's
its nordic neighbors and they are now
trying to push through a bill in
parliament
to be able to allow lockdowns of which
i i just don't think that's an accurate
representation i've seen that written
it's not true
they're not considering the type of
lockdown there is in the uk they have
they call the soft lockdown so they have
taken
certain measures and they have increased
the intensity of some measures in some
areas as you expect
so i think we become too uh obsessed
between uh
lockdown as an anti-lock downs it's
about what practical measures do you
take do you for example
as we've done in the uk close golf clubs
is that going to stop a single case it's
very expensive for the country
because you have to pay furlough
payments and so on
and you lose the tax revenue you'd
otherwise get from
golf clubs so i think rather than theory
it's practice
and we're saying in practice you can
open golf clubs
and pubs safely if you operate social
distancing and hygiene policies
as we've proved yeah because public
health england will say that amongst the
their science does show that amongst
those who have tested positive
the most common thing that those people
have done is dine out so i guess you can
presume
that's not right that's not right that's
what public health england has said
they said the most common thing is that
they went to supermarkets but of course
if you don't go to supermarkets
you can't eat everyone goes to go to a
supermarket that's the top thing
so lots of people go to pubs of course
the question is
do they catch the virus there but anyway
we're talking theory now
everyone's will be shortly will be
vaccinated
the news is and the thing is
can pub safely open at the end of march
operating social distancing
and hygiene policies that were agreed
with the health authority
and the government in july last year so
we opened very successfully
using those policies now everyone's
vaccinated
never mind the theory of sweden versus
denmark versus south dakota versus north
dakota
what will work you're keen to get you're
keen to get reopened that point you're
making very clearly
um tens of thousands of workers uh
weather spoons i know that
most of them i think have been on
furlough how many of them do you hope to
bring back
all of them every single one that's what
we have
yeah yeah well we've got 30 there were
40 000 when we closed down a year ago
there are over 37
000 now so we'd hope that they can all
come back